bonjour je m'appelle mathieu g27 et je
fais du parcours pour ceux qui ne savent
pas
au sport qui consiste à se déplacer
non en franchissant des obstacles
souvent dans la ville
vous avez sûrement vu des vidéos de
quelqu'un qui saute d'un toit un autre
mais en réalité c'est beaucoup plus que
ça le parcours te permet de voir la
ville différemment de regarder un banc
un mur une entrée parking où le toit
d'un immeuble et te dire
je pense que je peux sauter de la la je
crois que je m'en sens capable
mais je dois avouer que la sensation de
sauter d'un toit un autre c'est quelque
chose d'assez indescriptible
quand tu es devant le sanctuaire perds
et tu la mesure et qui à vérifier la
solidité de la réception ton élan tu a
craché sur les semelles de ses
chaussures et tu les a ensuite essuyé
pour avoir un maximum de la croche
rien n'est laissé au hasard
tu ce recul pour prendre tout le temps
nécessaire
à ce moment là plus rien ne peut
déconcentrer tué parfaitement concentré
sur ton unique objectif
tu commences à courir
et tu vas te concentrer sur têt dernier
pas parce que ce sont les plus
importants
tu poses enfin le pied sur bout du toit
et tu prends ton envol
tu allais rivés sur la réception et tu
arrive enfin après avoir fait une
roulade pour amortir le choc
tu te rends compte que finale
selon n'a duré qu'une seule seconde et
pourtant le cerveau va l'enregistrer
comme un souvenir immense
tu as en quelque sorte décupler le temps
c'est ce mélange de sentiments entre la
peur l'adrénaline la fierté le fait de
partager tout ça entre potes c'est ce
pour quoi j'ai revient à chaque fois en
quelques mots c'est ça le parcours
malheureusement j'ai pas toujours
ressenti cette sensation de liberté je
me souviens qu'au collège on avait une
cour de récré tout ce qui a pu classique
il y avait une immense parcelle d'herbe
et on n'avait pas le droit d'aller
dessus genre vraiment si tu allais
dessus c'était considéré comme un grand
rebelles et on pouvait limite envoyer en
taule corps
et avec le recul je me dis quand déjà tu
passes 8 heures de cours dans une salle
et que le moment où tu peux te détendre
un peu entre potes et de poser sur
l'herbe tu vois un gros panneau interdit
de marcher sur l'herbe je crois que j'y
arriverai jamais à comprendre
ça va beaucoup frustré
jusqu'à ce que je découvre une émission
qui a vraiment changé ma vie
cette émission c'est mieux et culotté
visiblement vous connaissez
le principe est très simple ces deux
potes qui partent en voyage en stop sans
argent et sans vêtements ils partent à
la rencontre des gens d'une part pour
avancer leurs voyages mais aussi tout
simplement pour les rencontrer et moi
quand je j'ai vu ça je me suis dit mais
c'est pas possible c'est trop bien cette
émission il faut que je teste
j'y croyais pas trop mais mais il
fallait que je teste
et je me souviens quand j'avais parlé à
mon père
m'avait dit ouais on va te revoir dans
une heure ou deux quand tu seras pris
une bonne averse sur la tête quoi mais
c'est comme ça à 18 ans que je me suis
lancé avec quelques potes dans notre
aventure nus et culottés
et on avait tellement de doutes sur la
réussite de cette aventure qu'on s'était
imprimer des fausses autorisations de
france 5 au cas où pour les montrer aux
gens
mais on n'en a pas eu besoin on n'en a
pas eu besoin parce qu'on a rencontré
des gens formidables
qui nous ont hébergés qui nous ont
accueillis on a pu partager un moment de
leur vie en étant plus du tout l'argent
au centre des échanges
et cinq jours après on était sûr
l'objectif qu'on s'était fixé faire du
pédalo sur le lac léman
on l'a fait quatre nuls d'affilée et à
chaque fois ça a marché
un marché parce qu'on se donnait pas du
tout le choix de repartir en arrière on
se disait on y va c'est parti
une fois que j'ai vu tout ça
j'aurais pu me dire bon là j'ai traversé
la france n'use en partant du une forêt
sans téléphone
quand je vais rentrer chez moi la
question ce sera forcément c'est quoi la
prochaine aventure
mais quand j'y réfléchis je comprends un
peu la réaction sceptiques de mon père
parce qu'aujourd'hui on vit dans une
société où il faut sécuriser faut
assurer le coup quand tu as des idées
que tu es jeune on disait cool c'est
bien c'est très bien d'avoir des choses
en tête mais assure au moins le coup si
jamais ça ne marche pas citer vraie
envie de marche pas au moins tu auras un
petit parachute des études
et en fait on vient casser complètement
le processus de créativité on crée des
barrières qui n'existe pas
est ce que je trouve dommage dans une
société c'est que la prise de risque
n'est pas du tout valorisé
et par peur d'échouer on ne tente pas
bien à la fin de ma troisième je suis
allé avec mon père au salon de
l'orientation pour me renseigner un peu
sur les formations professionnelles et
j'avais dit à mon père j'aimerais bien
être sur scène et raconter des histoires
aux gens
c'est ça qui m'intéresse du coup on
était allé voir un petit peu le gars qui
présentait les métiers du spectacle
et après lui avoir fait part de mon
projet le gamma effet on savait très
très compliqué il n'y a pas beaucoup de
travail
tu devrais être orientés vers autre
chose parce que ouais non franchement la
concurrence est très rude
et moi quand mon ado j'étais resté
bloqué là dessus on sans savoir trop
quoi dire
à cette époque-là
d'écouté parents tu écoutes les profs
écoute ce gars
t'as pas beaucoup de recul sur la vie du
coup il aura pu me dire bah si tu veux
vraiment y consacrer c'est possible ce
sera pas simple mais si tu bosse à fond
pourquoi pas non au lieu de ça
il m'avait dit je te brise son rêve mais
qu elle aura donc je les écoutais
l'écouté et j'ai fait des études pour
assurer le coup j'ai faire un iut
j'ai fait une licence et pour assurer le
coup j'ai fait un master sa geste et
bien sûr d'assurer le coup
et en 2018 quand j'ai terminé mes études
et j'ai commencé à chercher du travail
et ma soeur m'a embauché dans son argent
marchi sans trop m'en rendre compte j'ai
bossé trois ans de ma vie comme ça alors
c'était très cool hein mais
caché au fond de moi-même chaleix parce
que je voulais faire
j'avais besoin de changement c'était pas
une crise mais et j'avais besoin de me
séparer de tout le confort que j'avais
créé pour revenir à des choses qui
m'avait vraiment rendu heureux comme ces
cinq jours de nuit et culotté a pas
savoir où j'allais être dix minutes plus
tard
ou quand je faisais des sceaux sur les
toits quand je faisais du parcours
donc j'ai tout quitté j'ai quitté mon
appart j'ai quitté ma copine
j'ai quitté mon taf et j'ai rencontré
les potes du oui qui sont ce soir dans
la salle les potes qui partageait la
même passion que moi on a commencé à
faire des vidéos de parcours à rennes et
c'était vraiment fou on était tout le
temps tous ensemble
et on s'est dit mais à force de voir
tous les week-ends comme ça
pourquoi on essaierait pas d'en vivre au
lieu de se voir deux jours sur 7
pourquoi on essaierait pas de se voir
sept jours sur sept donc on a créé une
association
et
on a commencé
à c'est un appart
ont été très souvent six ou sept dans
cet appart à se marrer et à parler on
parlait beaucoup de voyages ont monté
des vidéos on voulait acheter un van et
partir à l'aventuré c'était ça le rêve
mais pour pouvoir faire ça on est
obligées se faire payer pour faire du
parcours ça c'est pas simple surtout
quand on est beaucoup
mais même si cet objectif était quand
même très très incertain
retrouvez avec eux le même esprit que
nous et culotté
on teste on verra bien il n'y a pas de
problème
et un jour après une session parcours à
aix en provence on avait vu une vidéo
d'un youtuber qui s'appelait partager
c'est sympa dans cette vidéo il montrait
des gens qui luttait contre la pollution
lumineuse en éteignant les enseignes
extérieures des magasins avec des
grandes perches il actionné des petits
boîtiers extérieur de pour les pompiers
et comme ça ça a été niée plein
d'enseignements
nous quand on a vu ça on s'est dit ok fo
conteste c'est trop bien mais sans les
perches déjà parce que la cause nous
touchent et puis on se renseigne un peu
on a appris que les anciennes extérieurs
doivent normalement être et peintre
entre 1h et 6h du matin
donc si on peut faire du parcours on
sort un truc qui nous fait marrer qui
lutte contre la surconsommation
énergétique et qu'en plus c'est nous qui
faisons respecter la loi
passer du bonheur
donc on se met en quête de ces petits
boîtiers
et on escalade les façades d'immeubles
et les gouttières
on a passé une soirée à faire ça c'est
pareil
on a fait une petite vidéo on a un film
et c'est avec nos téléphones
il retour à rennes on partage ça sur nos
réseaux
quand on se réveille le lendemain la
vidéo avait fait 700 millions se fait
complètement débordé
et la télé qui veut s'en mêler l équipe
de quotidiens qui vient à l'appart
qui fait un reportage sur nous
et après tout s'enchaîne nous fait des
interviews pour la bbc pour de guardian
pour une chaîne de télé en italie
et en fait cette petite vidéo a mis en
lumière notre groupe fait qu'on vous ait
des vidéos de parcours
et aujourd'hui on est huit dans
l'aventuré on voyage comme ça avec notre
vannes
ça fait rêver
en fait quand j'y réfléchis je me suis
rendu compte que je me suis entre
guillemets prouver j'étais capable
d'appartenir à cette société pour avoir
la force psychologique ensuite demandé
faire
pour vie pour vivre sur les routes à
faire des vidéos de parcours on a
sacrifié une partie de notre vie
et quand tu dis que quand tu grandis tu
te rends compte que le sacrifice est
inévitable quand tu veux entreprendre
quelque chose il ya forcément un
sacrifice sauf quand le sacrifice
tu choisis
dans ce cas là c'est plus un sacrifice
c'est un choix de vie
et pour moi c'est ça la liberté
sinon
on choisit la place
la ville est prof tes parents ou ce gars
du salon de l'orientation
on a accepté de sortir des codes de
notre société
alors on va pas dans les bars le samedi
soir n'a pas d'appart apud appartient
non et on n'a pas un travail classique
mais on vit nos rêves
on a découvert une nouvelle forme de
richesse
alors évidemment on n'a pas beaucoup
d'argent parce que c'est dur du vis du
parcours surtout à 8
mais on est riche
on sent riches parce que on est entre
potes on est riche parce qu'on est libre
n'est riche parce qu on fait ce qu'on
aime
et on est riche aussi parce qu'on sait
que le temps est bien plus précieux que
l'argent est en soi on sait comment
maintenant décupler le temps
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]